[Conan] On my last night, I checked out
one of Haiti's top groups, music bands,
Grammy-nominated Boukman Eksperyans.
And as you can imagine, I blended in seamlessly.
(Haitian roots music)
It was the perfect end to an unforgettable trip.
During my brief visit, I was blown away
by the warmth, generosity, independence,
passion and humor of the Haitian people.
The rest of the world needs to catch up
to what the Haitian people already know,
that they have all it takes to thrive as a nation.
You are an extraordinary people,
you're a beautiful people,
and I think great things are coming your way.
Viva Haiti!
(cheering)
I'm at a book stall in Haiti
and I just love the randomness of this book.
I don't know why.
This is my friend, Eric.
He's been helping us out on this trip.
He's been amazing.
We also found out that he is the Haitian Rock.
Give it to them.
(laughing)
I like him so much more than the Haitian Vin Diesel.
You're great, you're fantastic.
Oh thank you.
One more time.
Yeah.
(laughing)
Hey check it out.
Remember that tap-tap painting
I showed you earlier today?
Thony is the guy that made it.
This is going on a tap-tap.
Crazy, thank you.
You're welcome.
That looks sad.
I'm here at Ecole Nouvelle Zorange.
I'm gonna learn some Creole today.
It should go well.
(laughing)
(children chattering loudly)
I taught them all to misbehave.
I taught them.
I walked in to a very nice,
very respectful class,
and I taught them to misbehave.
I'm sorry.
I'm in Haiti and just now getting the news
about the government shutdown in the United States.
Thank god I'm in Haiti,
where the government actually works.